wir befürchten steigende preise für gas
und energie und lebensmittel zugleich
ist auch die wirtschaftliche perspektive
unseres landes fragil geworden wir sehen
das auch das wirtschaftliche wachstum in
den prognosen nach unten korrigiert wird
wir sind also in einer situation wo
gehandelt werden muss die
bundesregierung hat die menschen und die
betriebe in diesem jahr mit zwei sehr
umfänglichen entlastungs paketen
unterstützt daran werden wir ja im
nächsten jahr wie der bundeskanzler
gesagt hat auch anknüpfen zum ersten
januar wird es eine große wohngeldreform
geben um die menschen die steigende
heizkosten haben bei einem geringen
haushaltseinkommen zu unterstützen zum
ersten januar wird auch das neue
bürgergeld eingeführt dass menschen im
bezug der grundsicherung
unterstützen soll es geht darum die
lebenssituation ganz konkret von
gegenwärtig aber dauerhaft bedürftigen
menschen zu verbessern durch eine
anpassung des regelsatzes an die
inflationsentwicklung aber dass auch vor
allen dingen die teilhabe an arbeit an
beschäftigung für die menschen
erleichtert wird diese maßnahmen sind
auf den weg gebracht
zugleich droht aber 48 millionen
deutschen neben den steigenden
lebenshaltungskosten wegen etwa der
preisentwicklung beim gas droht 48
millionen deutschen eine massive
steuererhöhung zum ersten januar in
dieser zeit steigender
lebenshaltungskosten und fragiler
wirtschaftlicher perspektiven könnte die
menschen mit rund zehn milliarden euro
zusätzlich belastet werden
das tägliche leben wird teurer die
konjunktur schwächt sich ab und in diese
situation hinein wurde der start von der
inflation mit rund zehn milliarden euro
profitieren in diesen zeiten eine
steuererhöhung vorzusehen das ist nicht
fair
und das ist auch für die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung gefährlich der hintergrund
ist die sogenannte kalte progression
wir haben ja eine gewünschte
progression in unserem steuerrecht wir
haben einen linear progressiven wie es
heißt steuertarif das heißt wer ein
höheres einkommen hat derzeit nicht nur
in euro und cent höhere steuern sondern
auch prozentual steigt die steuerlast
ist die gewünschte progression man
könnte sagen starke schultern sollen
mehr tragen als die schmalen schultern
das ist die idee unseres steuerrechts
durch die inflationsentwicklung werden
aber menschen deren schultern gar nicht
breiter geworden sind trotzdem im
steuertarif nach oben geschoben und
belasteten das ist die sogenannte kalte
progression also eine mehrbelastung die
nicht zusammen hängt mit einer größeren
individuellen leistungsfähigkeit sondern
nur mit der entwicklung der inflation
ich habe deshalb jetzt eckpunkte
erarbeitet für ein inflationsausgleichs
gesetz mit dem diese schädliche kalte
progression diese steuererhöhung durch
unterlassung abgewendet wird um nicht
missverstanden zu werden meine damen und
herren man kann sehr wohl auch in dieser
situation politisch für steuererhöhungen
sein ich bin es bekanntlich nicht aber
man kann natürlich im politischen ideen
wettbewerb für steuererhöhungen seien
aber dann ist nach meiner auffassung
nötig in der öffentlichkeit und im
parlament dafür zu werben eine mehrheit
zu organisieren
also eine politische mehrheit gibt für
eine andere verteilungspolitik und eine
steuererhöhung dann ist das demokratisch
aber eine steuererhöhung gewissermaßen
durch unterlassung heimlich zu erreichen
das halte ich auch für demokratisch
nicht vertretbar
die eckpunkte des inflationsausgleichs
gesetz sind ein höherer grundfreibetrag
der komplett von der steuer befreit ist
eine veränderung des linear progressiven
steuertarifs die tarifeckwerte werden
nach rechts verschoben ein höheres
kindergeld und damit verbunden ein
höherer kinderfreibetrag
diese
maßnahmen die die kalte progression
ausgleichen sollen haben eine
gesamtstaatliche
finanzierung von zehn milliarden euro
würden also diese steuer erhöhung
abfinden dass profitieren 48 millionen
menschen davon wenn dieses
inflationsausgleichs gesetz beschlossen
er würde
rentnerinnen und rentner
sozialversicherungspflichtig
beschäftigte
selbstständige in der ganzen breite der
gesellschaft sind menschen davon
betroffen
das durchschnittliche volumen
einer abgewendeten belastung beträgt 192
euro
die anlage des inflationsausgleichs
gesetzes haben wir so vorgenommen dass
es die breite mitte der gesellschaft
ansprechen soll
bis hin zu dem anderthalbfachen des
durchschnittlichen einkommens ist eine
entlastung ich sage eine abwendung einer
zusätzlichen belastung vorgesehen das
anderthalbfache des
durchschnittseinkommens das ist nicht
die spitzen etage der gesellschaft
sondern das sind die qualifizierten fach
und führungskräfte das ist die
technikerin das ist der ingenieur
das sind die menschen die noch
tarifentgelte der gewerkschaften
beziehen das bedeutet also dass bis zu
einem einkommen von knapp über
60.000 euro es eine abwendung der
belastung gibt danach gibt es einen
deckel also über etwa 62.000 euro hinaus
gibt es keine
zusätzlichen entlastungen da ist also
das maximum erreicht beim etwa des
anderthalbfachen des
durchschnittseinkommens
ich habe bewusst darauf verzichtet
anders als in der vergangenheit den
tarif eckwerte der sogenannten
reichensteuer zu verschieben der bleibt
da wo er ist um zu unterstreichen dass
es hier darum geht die breite mitte der
gesellschaft anzusprechen denn die sind
auch in besonderer weise von der
inflation betroffen die von mir
geschilderten maßnahmen reichen auch bei
den spitzen einkommen aus um deren
inflations auswirkungen zu
beantworten da brauchen wir nicht noch
zusätzliche maßnahmen
die
der ausgleich der kalten progression
ist zum einen eine verfassungsrechtliche
verpflichtung das existenzminimum muss
steuerfrei gestellt werden und zum
anderen entspricht der
inflationsausgleich der ständigen
staatspraxis seit einigen jahren alle
meine vorgänger in den vergangenen
jahren haben die kalte progression
ausgeglichen beim grundfreibetrag aus
verpflichtung bei den tarifverlauf weil
es die ständige staatspraxis und ein
gebot der fairness ist und deshalb
möchte ich der bundesregierung und auch
der koalition mit diesen eckpunkten den
vorschlag unterbreiten gerade in der
zeit der inflation an dem festzuhalten
was verfassungsgebot und ständige
staatspraxis ist von der geübten praxis
der finanzpolitik ausgerechnet einer
fragilen wirtschaftlichen situation
abzuweichen wo menschen steigende
lebenshaltungskosten haben das wäre eine
falsche grad es wäre nicht nur nicht
fair es wäre auch für die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung unseres
landes von nachteil und deshalb diese
eckpunkte eines inflationsausgleichs
gesetz mit denen wir jetzt in die
beratung innerhalb der bundesregierung
eintreten haben sie vielen dank als wir
einmal zusammen was ja alles plant vor
weggeschickt das weiß er auch ganz genau
die koalitionspartner die müssen da noch
zustimmen und da gab es auch schon ein
bisschen kritik arbeiter haben jetzt
erstmal auf die wichtigsten punkte sein
plan der plan des finanzministers das
kindergeld soll steigen dann nochmals
auf 2024 soll es nochmal steigen also
erst um 8 oder nochmal um sechs euro
auch der grundfreibetrag steigt an der
entlassungen um insgesamt 10 milliarden
euro sind geplant das kostet ihnen
sozusagen das paket man muss sagen aber
die inflation die spielt natürlich auch
die steuerkassen voll also insofern das
ist für funkel kalte progression
deswegen macht christian lindner dass
diese schreckenswort also dass man weil
zum beispiel die löhne steigen im moment
als inflationsausgleich plötzlich in
eine höhere steuerklasse rutscht dass
der staat höhere steuereinnahmen hat und
man dann eben ja heimlich belastet wird
das wird jetzt ausgeglichen wenn es da
christian lindner geht vor allen dingen
eben durch diese maßnahmen jetzt muss
noch durch die koalition noch durch den
bundestag und dann spüren wir es
hoffentlich bald in unserem portmonee
[Musik]